[Music]
[Applause]
i would stay with my partner
even if they cheated on me amber
somewhat agree
charlie stay with the partner if they
cheated
um disagreed
[Music]
i'm leah and i'm leanna and we have been
together for four years and we've been
living down the street from each other
for
a long time and we never knew my name is
nyla
we're married married for four seven no
married for
almost nine we got married on 12 12 12.
so i shouldn't have forgotten that but
it's all good
i'm amber jay born and raised in los
angeles county
my name is charlie la pastora been
married for three years i put a ring on
it man
and we fun fact got married on 11 11.
and so we love that you guys are married
on 12 12.
you get it hi mohina hi i'm blake we're
both 18 from palm springs and we've been
together for
two years hey everyone i'm latasha this
is norris
hey we've been engaged for what nine
months now
and together for almost six years
i have considered breaking up with my
partner
leanna somewhat agree leah
somewhat agree jamal strongly disagree
nyla strongly agree
we actually did break up oh
i thought it was like recent oh
looking forward amber
disagree wait was strong charlie
disagree agree
blake uh disagree latasha
somewhat agree norris disagree
we did break up our relationship was
going so well on that curve up and it
was going so quick and i felt like
this is just going too well that we're
just going to fall off
once i was able to relinquish all of
that
extra baggage that i thought i wanted
her to be for me
i think that's when everything got
better on my end i think every couple
goes through that
stage in the relationship where you know
it may seem good at the very beginning
but then you question some things
because you're not clicking or you're
not
you're butting heads but there's this
point where you kind of
need to put some distance and it helps
you refrain your mind about this person
and about yourself
you get clarity then you come back
together being a first generation like
mixed race
muslim person and him coming from a
republican family
uh there's just a lot of tension i
remember his teammates
the people he trusted the most they
would call me like a terrorist for being
muslim part of al-qaeda
my family had enough of that after like
a big disagreement with his family
so they were like you're done move on
but i just remember him um
calling me crying like i didn't just
take him back automatically
i saw that he made change he stood up to
the people he trusted the most and i
think we're stronger
i'm okay with my partner watching
porn leah strongly agree
leanna agree jamal strongly agree
nyla agree amber strongly disagree
and charlie strongly disagree hina
disagree blake disagree with tasha
somewhat agree norris agree
pornography erect my family like my
parents were together they were strong i
was raised in a strong christian
household and then pornography
crept in i did not want that to have any
place
in our marriage and so from from early
on i i was like this isn't happening and
so i might be extreme
to people but you know there there's
times when even when i'm scrolling on
the gram like there's like women who
scantily clad i want my eyes to be
focused on my bride
a lot of times people think you know
pornography and they just think about
like the real raunchy hardcore stuff
and not like the everyday sort of like
softcore pornography that
are you know confronted with every day
but i did the same thing where i went
through like a massive instagram cleanse
where i had to just go like oh can't
follow them no more can't follow them no
more
she doesn't look at it on her own
but sometimes i would if i were just
like home alone you feel me
so when she will come home she's just
like you're sleeping i know you did
something you know
it did strengthen our communication like
oh if you do watch it let's watch it
together and then we can go to sleep
but the reason why i strongly did
disagree a while back then is because i
felt like
am i doing something wrong like is that
why you're watching it like you know
am i not satisfying you but now it's
like
where'd you learn that at you know when
i started watching it like i couldn't
stop
i didn't realize the effects it had on
me until i met hina
and then we discussed like our
boundaries as she was saying like yeah
no pornography
when i first heard that i was like oh
that's easy like i can quit it like
nothing nice nothing
i stopped watching it and then i was
like like god like i couldn't even like
focus like i was thinking about it all
the time
when i would hug her and kiss her and
stuff and then it just like
it brought back memories of watching it
like somehow i don't know how
but it just brought back memories i was
so confused
and i like hated myself for thinking
that way and then it just
honestly it put me in like a deep
depression because yeah just like what
charlie was saying it's kind of with his
family it sneaks its way at it you know
it ruins everything i would stay with
my partner even if they cheated on me
lyanna somewhat agree
leah agree jamal
agree nyla somewhat agree
amber somewhat agree
charlie stay with the partner if they
cheated
um disagree
you know strongly disagree blake
strongly disagree latasha somewhat
disagree
and norris disagree yeah i mean i think
a marriage is a contract and i own a
business so if somebody if the other
party
doesn't hold up their end of the
contract i get to leave
that you know bye it's a contract and
for us we also believe it's it's a
covenant as well
we became before each other between us
two and a holy god i didn't say strongly
disagree because i believe there is
grace but at the same time
that is such a serious offense i know
having been hurt before
you know in a relationship where someone
was unfaithful it's so painful to me and
i i'm
i feel man and so like if that were to
happen
and you to take the initiative to
physically
like just even the thought of that
pisses me off yeah
loyalty is incredibly important to the
both of us and something that we talked
about
from the get-go and so for me too i
can't even fathom if that were to happen
i would be livid as well but because
this is a marriage and
we both agreed to this then i would try
to muster up the strength
to forgive it's like i made a commitment
to you and that i won't break look at
some people say you can't
stay together for the kids but we have
amazing kids we got a great relationship
company is thriving she's doing well in
her job
just bought a new house it's like don't
mess that up don't mess around
i wasn't sure what he was gonna say and
i struggled with what i was gonna say
because i know
what i thought 10 12 years ago
but now as you mentioned your
perspective changes
on what would break the commitment
like i'm a pretty jealous person like if
i'm in the mall with her because she
she's super beautiful and then like
people always like stare at her and i'll
just mad dog then like
stare them down and cover it with a bag
and just
she's beautiful i know guys like her i
said listen i see the dms
you know what i mean there's nothing
any of us can do about that that's just
life but it's how you
how i respond to that exactly that's how
she's responsible
that makes me trust her and makes me say
i'm not tripping on that but the
generation now
is cheating is okay like they call it
sneaky links now
meaning like oh you're basically meeting
up with somebody that you shouldn't be
people glorify that like oh i'm a number
one side chick why do you want to be a
number one side chick
and why don't you want to be somebody's
actual mane and keep it faithful
you have to also set your boundaries
online hey i don't want you on this
dating app hey i don't want you
to go and swipe up on some risky picture
on snapchat i think
those are the aspects that we're kind of
talking about that
older generations didn't really have to
deal with yeah we did we had black
planet
we were getting crazy on it what's that
[Laughter]
i did not expect a black planet
reference today
i would like to have children
leanna strongly agree leah
strongly agree jamal strongly agree
nyla strongly agree amber
strongly agree charlie strongly agree
ina somewhat agree blake some would
agree
latasha somewhat disagree norris
angry if you would have asked me this
five years ago
before i met him it would be strongly
disagree i don't know i've just never
felt called to be a mom
and i know that family is something
that's important to him so i think
you know we had a big conversation about
that before we got engaged
and i know for me previously it would
have been
strongly agree through our conversation
i had to really think about it because
it's like i'm
not pushing a human being out who am i
to you know just go
you having babies like you know i'm not
you know i can't do that
like just to get a little personal real
quick i have been trying
so we have like i'm trying not to be
emotional but we have to go through
another step
to conceive it hasn't been really
working out so we just try to keep like
the good faith and like to hope that we
do
have a blessing someday but yeah
so i'm just keeping hope alive
oh my god i'm such an ugly crier
did impact our relationship because
before we even started i told her i said
look if it doesn't work the first try
don't go so hard on yourself we just
took a break all together
sometimes i felt like oh us taking a
break has an effect
on her she's basically seeing that i
don't want to do it anymore and that's
not the case
i just feel like mentally i needed to
get myself together and to be strong
to the point where i can look at that
test and if it does stay negative
i will be okay i just want to build a
whole team so
she's having him too don't be looking
like i'm just doing it by myself
absolutely not yeah no
i would love to have a family but it
doesn't mean i
can't adopt so long as i'm healthy and
capable of bringing
a healthy child up and having the
economic ability to support a child
because
growing up in a low-income household i
do know like the effects and
also our political atmosphere do i want
to raise a child
who will obviously be a person of color
in a political atmosphere that
takes advantage or undermines people of
color i can definitely relate to that i
think i have a lot of the same
concerns raising a black child is what
we
would have and that it has a different
set of
challenges i think unfortunately it
shouldn't be different but it is
and i also have mental health issues in
my family
that's something that scares me a little
bit you know i wasn't
i was in the bed last uh couple night
two nights ago i was late
i wasn't what are you guys coming out
and i was laying down we didn't
okay i took a picture i was like there's
my wife
my youngest and my son to my left and i
was engulfed in all this love and it was
crazy i never ever i'm never going to
think about whether
i should bring a child into this world
don't think about the world just what do
you want
and that's don't let the world determine
whether you're going to have a child
i just know that if i'm not at a great
place in my life
i will rub off my trauma onto my child
and i could not live with myself knowing
that
i did that to someone that i couldn't
raise someone up to be
as best as they can as a social worker
you touched on a very important point
which is mental health
there's a lot of people having children
creating little humans
and they are physically emotionally
not together to be able to raise another
human being
in this already troublesome world you
guys touched on the race thing too
i'm half white half filipino and so i
always was like oh yeah i never
considered myself a minority but then i
realized when somebody punched me in the
face
and then verbally you know hearing
things being made fun of because i'm
asian
and i realize that our kids are going to
be colored our kids are going to have
brown skin
the lord led me to my filipina queen and
we're going to have mixed babies and i'm
mixed and i want us to
and we're going to embrace that and
we're going to bring them into the world
if we don't have that foundation
you know they're going to be coming into
a home that's not built right so we're
trying we're building right now and it's
not and we're growing
that's what i would say today that's
fire
i believe in soulmates lyanna
somewhat agree leah agree jamal
agree nyla somewhat agree
amber strongly agree charles
strongly agree hina somewhat agree
blake agree latasha
strongly agree and norris
somewhat disagree there's so many
external factors that go
into what makes a relationship you know
where did you grow up
who did you hang around how much money
you make
where did you go to school to say soul
mate kind of leaves it up to this kind
of
fake you know outside of myself kind of
thing
i made a decision to be with latasha and
latasha made a decision to be with me
i said somewhat agree because i don't
think you just have one
soulmate i would define a soulmate as
someone who brings out the best in you
i remember like the first night we
started talking we stood up till like
six in the morning just on the phone
like i was so tired but i just feel like
i could talk forever and i was like you
know what like one day i'm gonna marry
you and this is like the third day
she was like what is wrong with you it's
just a weird feeling you just know when
it happens
when we first like actually like met
face to face we were talking about
something personal in our lives which is
cancer
my mom and my grandma had cancer i don't
know
if you want to share i had cancer she
had cancer when she was little
no one i have ever dated understood how
i felt
it was three days until we met and i
said i love you i felt like this is my
person
i feel like i'm dating my my best friend
like this is my soul mate and then four
years into now we just stare at each
other and be like
yeah you're stuck with me for life like
we we went through the worst
we got through it we feel like we can
defeat anything that comes our way
when you know you know i personally was
in a mentally emotionally physically
abusive relationship
and you know i thought i loved that
person but that wasn't love
so oh gosh why am i getting emotional
i'm just really grateful because with
charlie
i really do feel like god has blessed me
with a soul mate that truly respects
loves and honors me with his whole heart
and he doesn't just say it
he walks the talk and he he puts in
daily
action to show that to me it was the
magnet it was the holy spirit that drew
us together because i have never
known something and been so confident
than amber jay
like this is who i was we were designed
for each other
we talked about this too we think that a
lot of people settle in relationships
and we want to just
just encourage everyone that hey there
is somebody out there for you just gotta
wait and it's tough it sucks to wait
but if you wait you will find the right
one i knew it when i knew it
and that was it and it's hard to explain
everybody wants to try to come up with
fancy words i just knew you
were my wife i just needed to work
towards
the goal of you being with me forever
that's how it was for me too
i knew this was the woman i wanted to
marry but it was a long time
before i felt like i was worthy enough
for her
to marry me if you guys you know want to
show each other some valentine's day
love however you want
um that would be the time to do it right
now
[Laughter]
[Music]
happy valentine's day everyone
you